Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so this is going
to be an explanation for X 23.
The way their using her in the movie the future
of the Wolverine character.
So let's break it down.
The real point of the latest trailer is just
to give you a better idea for the story and
confirm the fact that it is the Laura Kinney
X 23 character.
So if you have no idea who that is, she is
the 23rd attempt to replicate the weapon X
program because the sample they had was damaged.
She wound up becoming of female clone.
Instead of a mail clone like.
They originally intended, but the person in
charge of the program Xander Rice is actually
the son of someone that Wolverine himself
killed in the original weapon X program so
he has a beef against, Wolverine, but this
close created from his genetic material and
she has adamantine clause, but her skeleton
is regular, so one of the biggest questions
I had in my trailer video yesterday was how
does she grow if she has adamantine bones
and I almost forgot there actually is a new
round of the Deadpool giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video.
It's a $20 comics all and she giftcard, but
in the same way that Wolverine revolted, just
completely went berserk after he came out
of the tank in the weapon X program so does
Laura Kinney and the reason she's named Laura
Kinney is because one of the other people
in that program was named Dr. Kinney she was
tasked with raising her.
So the movie does a good job of explaining
that where like the little girl has a mother,
but technically because she's a clone, she
has no mother she just a piece of Wolverine,
so she's the closest thing that he has to
a daughter and I know a lot of you are asking
about DAC and Wolverine son from the comics
all do a separate video about that because
it's a completely separate thing with her
trying to keep the movie as simple as possible.
So in this universe.
There is only X 23 there's no DAC and so X
23 is raised in captivity of swords for about
seven years training with the doctor that
was responsible for creating her, but the
person in charge.
Xander Rice isn't happy with the progress
she's making they're trying to train a killer
here it's the weapon X program she just as
normal little girl, so he create something
called the trigger sent and uses it on Dr.
Kinney causing Laura X 23 to hold out on her
and kill her best friend.
So make all the trigger jokes you want, but
that's basically what's happening in these
trailers here where she goes in a berserker
rage, to try and save Logan from these people
in the context of the movie in the scenes
is just a little bit different because you
have a really old Logan it's like 2029 that's
the year so it's said way after that days
of Future past post-apocalyptic timeline member
at the end of that movie they fix things.
So imagine this taking place.
Well after that the director said he wanted
to be far enough away from those events that
there wasn't any mixing or matching with plot
line like this was just the next episode.
This was like, way further in the future.
So most of Logan's regeneration powers have
Wayne he doesn't heal as fast and it hurts
him to fight.
So he doesn't want to fight, but the X 23
character is fresh off the genetic printing
press she has all of his ferocity, so she's
like this X-Acto blade of rage.
Whereas, Wolverine is kind of like the dolt
instrument.
So he can still totally hold out when he needs
to, when he's pushed over the line, but for
the most part you have to imagine that he
is a lot like the older Prof. X here, he just
doesn't look it.
So he's very tired and Prof. X is another
matter to that's a whole other video the death
of Prof. X there been about 10 times in the
comics that Wolverine is died there also been
a couple big story arcs with a killed off
Prof. X, but the adamantine them.
So like I said she has a regular skeleton
but just adamantine clause.
That's how she grows normally.
So what happened is is they bombarded her
with radiation to force the activation of
her X gene just in the same way the Deadpool
movie bombarded him with all kinds of tests
to try and activate his X gene once she does
they bond her clause with adamantine him and
then she makes her scape Wolverine style just
in the same way he holds out and just kills
everybody and runs off.
But because she's so mad at Wolverine for
making her creation possible she killed her
best friend she thinks of herself as a monster
so she goes after the only person she knows
is ultimately responsible.
So she blames Wolverine and tries to track
him down a bunch of people close to her diet.
But then when she finally tracks Wolverine
down.
They come to terms he explains that he knows
what's going on and she gets arrested by Capt.
America, so the avengers the heroes the X-Men
they feel like she's not responsible for all
the debts that are on her head as she tried
to escape she goes on to start leading a normal
life trying to be a superhero in the marvel
universe but you still have Xander Rice in
the weapon X people in the reverse of this
movie try to track her down, so in the comics
she was already fully grown when she tracked
Wolverine down she still just a little girl
in this movie.
But what does that say about the future of
the character so we understand her past.
Now we know what she does in the movie she's
basically like a wolverine that's fresh off
the printing press totally bad ass totally
ferocious, but what are they gonna do it this
movie is so far in the future are they going
to use the character so the director said
that he didn't intend her to take Wolverine's
place or his mantle, but he hopes the fans,
embrace or like they really enjoy the character
so it makes it sound like the end of this
movie doesn't suddenly time travel into the
past like there's no crazy twist.
It just, a bookend for the character where
she just goes on and tries to lead a normal
life.
Whatever ends up happening to the Wolverine
character.
So with that in mind that just leaves the
other X-Men films to reboot the character
with another actor if they want if they're
not gonna do it Deadpool, Wolverine crossover,
which I do think is still very possible but
the real opportunity here for X 23 her future
in the X-Men universe.
I think is with the X force movie.
So Wolverine has a long history with X force.
It's like a more hardcore version of X-Men
I 40 done a couple X force video so add links
at the end of this, but during volume 3, X
23 joined the team so you could just do a
version of that.
So you get your Wolverine character even though
it's not Wolverine they don't have to completely
reboot the character ahead of schedule.
They can still leave room for Hugh Jackman
to come back and do it Deadpool crossover
if he wants I think it's gonna be a couple
years for the even talk about what can happen
with Wolverine going forward, but X 23 still
wide open.
So let me know they do X force which they
are doing that movies and development.
Do you want them to include the X 23 character
but because of all the timeline problems.
There's a couple hoops that you have to jump
through, so I'd be cool with whatever version
they want to go with that they want to go
with the younger version.
Just like in this movie or if they want to
go with a fully grown clone to be great to
let me know how do you want Laura Kinney to
appear in the other X-Men movies the beauty
of all this is that it sounds like there's
going to be a soft reboot for the main X-Men
films anyway so I feel like whatever they
decide to do, it will totally be cool as long
as it's a good movie.
That's all people care about.
Just remember the Deadpool movie is actually
going to give birth to X force because cable
has to come first.
So this is all couple years down the road
so there's plenty of time to figure it out.
Let me know in the comments what kind of X-Men
universe videos you guys want me to do going
forward under you guys are big fans a Deadpool
big fans of Wolverine but if there any X-Men
related videos you guys want me to do or explainers
just let me know in the comments speaking
of reboots, they just started announcing the
actors that are on the shortlist for the Green
Lantern movie.
It will probably change, but it's actually
a pretty interesting list, and it involves
Bradley Cooper, there's a whole area story
about his audition for the original Green
Lantern movie that he lost out to Ryan Reynolds
on.
So I'll probably do a video for that on Saturday.
There's also some new Star Wars episode 8
I'm going to post.
So it's going to be great while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to learn
all about the rock joining the DCEU as black
Adam he's going to wreck everything it's going
to be awesome and you can click here to learn
all about what's going on with Deadpool 2
thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!